I want to tell you guys and share with you guys what I consider to be my secret weapon
and it should be yours as well.
Okay, this is called the pullback and the reason I'm putting this video right here,
we just got done talking about the four steps to the perfect prospecting script.
I want to tell you about the pullback because this is going to be an opportunity where you're
probably first going to need to use this.
Okay, I'm going to tell you a couple of the situations in which you would use it.
I'm going to tell you how to properly use it and I'm going to tell you how often you
should use it so you don't overuse it, okay, and if you actually can overuse it.
So first of all, the pullback, what the pullback is, is it's you basically making a statement
that lets them know, hey, it puts them in their place.
It checks them and lets them know, hey, you need this more than I need this, okay?
That's the pullback.
Pulling away.
And you know, for the first couple steps, you know, one, two, three, who I am, what
I'm doing, what's the deal, transition, it's been go, I'm coming at them, I'm coming at
them, I'm coming at them, I'm coming at them and a lot of times you're going to need at
this point to do a pullback and what this is going to do is it's going to put you back
in control because you need people coming to you.
You need to be in control of the deal and so the pullback is something that you can
use any time, there's a couple different places that you can use this but I will say
this, couple rules of thumb with the pullback.
First of all, you could use this as many times as you need and you're not going to ruin the
deal.
You are not going to ruin the deal.
As long as you're talking to the right people and you're not being salesy and you're doing
the stuff right and you're giving leads in advance, you will not lose a deal by doing
too many pullbacks.
I promise you.
That's the cool part.
You don't have to worry about overusing the pullback, okay?
Here's a couple places I like to use it.
This is a really good point I like to use it at because sometimes, and I've seen this
and you guys have probably seen this in the group, is you get through, you do your pitch
and the business owner, they're all yeses, baby.
Yeah, sounds good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, cool.
Sounds good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's all yes.
No questions.
No objections.
No nothing.
You're like, dude, this is a golden ticket.
This guy is sold.
That's what you're thinking in your head.
Let me tell you what.
Truth is, this guy or this lady is too scared to tell you no and so it's coming out as yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Really?
They couldn't be further from a yeah.
So if you start getting the yes guy, the yes lady, I want you to use a pullback.
Something like this, okay?
You get to the end and everything's a yes.
Hey, I'm gonna send you a couple free leads.
We're gonna talk in a couple days.
How's that sound?
Cool.
Sounds good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And they're rushing you and it's just yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
And you're like, this sounds too good to be true.
It is.
Okay?
Here's what you're gonna do.
You're gonna stop them and say, hey, look, that sounds good.
I just want to double check.
First of all, don't take this wrong, but Jack, shoot me straight here, man.
I'm a grown ass man.
Are you interested in growing your business or are you just too scared to tell me no?
And I know, guys, I know that sounds bold, but I don't got time to waste these people,
okay?
So I'm literally gonna say, hey, Jack, real quick, before I hang up, I just don't want
to waste your time.
I don't want to waste my time.
I'm a grown ass man here, so shoot me straight.
Are you interested in growing your company or you just don't want to tell me no?
Because these are jobs that are coming in.
I only work with one company per area.
So if this isn't something like you don't want to grow and whatever, that's cool.
Just let me know now.
But just don't waste my time, okay?
And I know you're like, oh my gosh, you're gonna ruin the deal.
Nope.
Just the opposite, okay?
Just the opposite.
What you're gonna do is you're gonna wake their ass up.
And if they've been sitting there sleeping going, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, if they actually
are interested, you know what they're gonna do?
They're gonna all of a sudden come after you.
They're gonna go, oh, no, no, no, no, man, listen.
It's funny.
He's like, sorry, I'm driving.
And I kind of sound distracted, but I'm really interested.
Me and my partner or I was actually just talking to my wife or I was just talking to my husband
and I was just saying how much I'm tired, sick and tired of home.
They will start to sell you.
And the other cool part is if they're not following you and they really are the yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes, but they just don't want to tell you no, you know what they're gonna
say?
They're gonna say, yeah, man, like I don't want to, like I really don't want to waste
your time.
And if you have somebody else, like we're good.
We're good.
Okay.
And you're just gonna give them an opportunity to just walk away and you're gonna give them
an out.
Because what happens a lot of time with these yes, yes, yes, is you hang up the phone.
You're jacked.
You post to the group.
I just got somebody hooked, baby.
Let's go.
Okay.
Guess what happens?
You get the lead.
Get them on the phone.
You get Janet on the phone.
You go to call Jack back.
Jack doesn't answer.
Oh, Jack's on a job.
Hey, Janet.
Jack's gonna be calling you.
No problem.
24 hours later.
Jack's gone.
Jack's ghost mode, baby.
Jack is off.
Jack's phone number's changed.
Like guys, that guy's ghosting you.
You will never hear from them again.
And the problem is they were never following you in the first place.
They were too scared to tell you no.
And yes, I know that sounds funny because we're talking about grown ass men and women
lying to your face.
It happens every single day.
So I love using the pullback at the end of step four, the transition, to just make sure
they are following me.
That's if I, you know, if it sounds too good to be true, use the pullback, okay?
The other end of that is if someone is kind of being short with you, they're kind of acting
too busy.
They're acting like they're doing you a favor, like, yeah, I mean, I'm busy, but like I can
take some jobs if you want to send them to me.
In my head, I'm like, look, bro, you don't understand.
I'm not like, I got too much going on to be doing favors, right?
Like I'm happy to send you some to earn your business, to gain your trust, but I'm not
just like, you don't need to do me a favor, okay?
And I'll use a pullback then and I'll go, hey, just real quick, like, just, I want you
to know I only work with one company.
So if this is going to be a burden for you to take on more work, by like, make no mistake,
I don't need you to take on this work.
I'm asking you if you're hungry to go, are you hungry to go?
And I know that's a little aggressive and do I say it that bold every time?
No, sometimes do I?
Yes, because I'm just feeling it and I'm just not in the mood.
You guys can say this in your own way.
You don't need to be that bold, but you need to convey the fact that, hey, you need to
let them know that they need you more than you need them.
And I need you guys to mentally realize you don't need them.
There are 20, there are at least five to 20 to 50 different options in each city, in each
service that you can work with.
Guess what?
There's only one of you.
And we forget this.
We think that all of a sudden we got one option, we got one option that's the person and if
they don't do it, we're screwed.
No, that's not the truth.
The truth is you're the only person and you're the one that has what they need and you know
that because they're already paying for ads.
So get that in your damn mind and start using pullbacks and be bold.
And I do want to mention this and I'll talk about this, I'll talk about pullbacks later
in future videos.
You're also going to be able to use a pullback anytime during the process where the deal
sounds shaky, where the customer's not answering the phone, where the customer is just wasting
your time or you feel like they're wasting your time, use the pullback.
It is literally the secret weapon and I know it's very, very scary, especially the first
time you're like, oh my gosh, I just got through this really scary pitch and they said yes
and now I'm going to be that bold to just throw it all away.
Nope, you're not throwing it away.
You are just sifting out the crappy from the people that are actually serious, you're sifting
out the people who are not serious from the ones that are ready to rock and roll.
The pullback is a freaking secret weapon, master it, get used to it, I'll try and drop
some swipes but really the principle is you just need to convey that they need you more
than you need them.